hey this is Hans Kim from youtube.com
and I'm here at The Players Championship
we all know about golf the hole-in-one
the round into rubbing in the round
let's see what the people have to say
how do you feel about golf today sir hey
what's up man hey how are you a lot of
Asians on this tour and the players a
lot of them it's too many if you ask me
yeah you're right thanks hey no problem
what does golf mean to you I'm not very
good do what you like to hear a joke of
mine sure go ahead
hey why is Tanner a white person's name
it's so it's like Tanner than what
you're white [ __ ] good to be
here enjoying golf together with all our
international brothers and sisters I was
born in New Jersey I've been away my
whole life I actually avoid it as much
as possible especially nowadays you know
let's just have a good time could I
stand in between you guys like you're my
father's my name is Hans Kim with
Motorola sports.com Tony Conigliaro
from Bridgewater New Jersey I'm from New
Brunswick are you serious yeah Rutgers
hey Rutgers the Gamecocks yeah they
thought that game the Scarlet Knights
Scotland Rick Conigliaro Wayne New
Jersey home of the night 69 Little
League World Series
chimps of the world congratulations your
children are very talented thank you
thank you they're good with a bat you
say they're good with a bat hey I'm
walking here
I have a bear I'm good with it hey what
are you trying to cover here I'm trying
to cover the energy of the human beings
that occupy this planet Wow
well we got ABC Sports we got to see you
next I'm in the castle Yanni brothers
you know you got the coronavirus going
on right now and all that going on
interest rates are tanking and people
are scared and but we're in a good place
right now I mean can't really ask for
much more you got the green grass the
white ball and the heavy hands swinging
away absolutely a lot of countries can't
do that
you know you dealt with dealt with what
you have and that's it
what about Germany home and the free
land of the brave yeah absolutely
positively thank you for uh you know
being a part of the American economy I
do stand-up comedy and I live in a van
down by the river and you are real to me
up all depends on what you want I want
to not be cold anymore
do your homes come with heating they do
come with it they do come with heating
yeah I'm sold
though let's just try to talk to this
guy
hello sir
it's not somebody talking to us what was
your name today to be honest I know
there's a lot of white people have you
seen any Asians were they coughing are
you trained to watch out for
coughing Asians I'm concerned you mean
the body call I don't want to get you
fired but do you smoke weed on the job
please hire this man he doesn't even
hate white people I do a little bit hi
everybody believer it so I don't look at
nobody any different even if someone
blood green I'd still like them if
somebody bled green I'm in hell away
have you seen any Asians with green
blood tonight nope there's a cool
stadium or whatever school Park
youtube.com HTTP video sharing platform
maybe I could humor you with my comedy
oh this guy goddess man is this
recording goddess man what the [ __ ] a
bless English no me digas
Oh par for the course you're at the
Players Championship right here to watch
the players play like they do on them
things like every day big beats history
exceed gangsters roaming and parties
don't start until not in the morning
Flair's championship how do you feel
about today thank you
the workers need to unite and form
unions what do you think about that
depends on the the workers that's true
let's start coughing please don't sorry
Oh kidding I don't have it I don't know
of anybody else that does either I guess
yeah right yeah I mean you'd have it if
you did exactly how do you know I'm
kidding